yeah you know when to welcome to this
video I am junior 64 very Alonso Garcia
ok another Bank of you completely amazed
how popular is minor G I get it like I
many n or one out of three games
ourselves I never understand what
attracts white players to it you weaken
your position you have this bad
development with white I don't know it
looks look strange to me we now
understand that currently income then
once development is fine but you see
what happens now black opens up the
position and I don't really think that
white pieces are well positioned okay so
d phi 496 was was a sloppy move a short
85 immediately that was bad i was really
bad
what if I get in d5 that's really really
excellent that's another problem that I
think oftentimes it's white chapters
have this d 4 hole but I mean it's ok M
is definitely okay I'm not sure he
another 45 i need you i want to get rid
of those problem pieces these pieces to
the pawn on d6 and bishop I'm a bit
surprised that you took 26 it just looks
like it strengthens my structure
you
is very keen on giving me a activity and
I'd be three wins material I don't know
it doesn't actually it takes takes okay
one we should take the h7 and at the end
he takes a one so that does not win
material is it a good position at least
probably it isn't ok I think I just go
back intending mc3 tending c34 for more
Forks but i think i need to get out of
potential checks on the light squares so
what's the deal here 95 is hanging and
my lights my light squares are
definitely long ago absolutely
I can play be three again I don't know
if that's this much let's see
now i don't know if i should just take i
mean it's not bad this is also
interesting intending to claim and takes
and 93 he's got a three though which I
kind of disregarded because it doesn't
but it does threaten yeah i mean i was
thinking a three is kind of a non-move
but he can do it probably probably good
then it is the best move for white
yeah what else is there I mean okay some
forcing was taken at six energy for
things like that don't know yeah could
have done it quicker as forward what was
the point or was what was what exactly
what's the alternative let's aim yeah
probably have to go back I know it's not
completely hanging there it let's go
back
to h4 moon
Queen to h4 would be dangerous
absolutely dangerous
ok
g6 is almost hanging mainly place
without this rook them so I would be
somewhat surprised we have the flat out
wind which it's not completely
impossible of course my idea is simple
Bishop define Bishop takes me to so nine
morning when he has got no background
and what time is that really working a
we've got a one covered but you want
covered which I did not see ad Jesus I
didn't see that he covers it oh my god
and then then that was bad promoting on
c1 I thought I can just made them here
basically with Quincy three
yeah queen d for oh my god ah I'm losing
this this friggin game unbelievable from
that position great
I just can't take the bishop okay I was
on time now right check like horses and
relax it was just too crazy in yep I
mean here I was thinking when I when I
did you did this promotion I was just
thinking I'm winning with Quincy three
at the end and I can probably do
whatever I mean I don't believe I cannot
believe that this pls dolan ok so let's
have a look I was pretty strange yeah I
made a mistake I'm not sure that night I
should probably do this immediately and
get to this position and then 96 and so
on then terms prevent 984 which I felt
was a bit annoying yeah I don't know he
gave me 94 for free and then I got to
fibrin I was surprised that he took only
six that just strengthens my position
was rather thinking this and I should be
ok with those those nights but why this
is certainly also find engine is equal
and equal and here here I'm just clearly
better of course that cannot be good yes
with the bishop en blanc spawn mess
Queen B 6 was stronger word I mean here
you just have to if you are not getting
checkmated and it should be possible are
ya b3 was already good and like it's
just clearly better 94 so it's great ok
yeah I missed on tons of things c3 c3
why does that work ah because he I can
just take and win the book that's cute
today and so I miss the ton of wins yeah
this was was probably not
very good next position is so good that
he can make the what we'd move just I
mean here I completely lost my composure
because I was thinking initially this
but the Queen ear covers Yvonne I was
really close to playing lat move and now
it's a it's a whole Messier and I'm
probably not subjectively because a
point now it's also dangerous and okay
we had this time scramble that was
that's what happens sometimes okay
thanks for watching